is how much does the next CEO really
need to have a vision for what this
product should be and how to reconcile
some of the inconsistencies well I don't
think of them as inconsistencies I think
of the you know you have to evolve your
products have to evolve I mean Twitter
started out as a text-only product
obviously we've evolved dramatically
from that the two other products we've
brought to market our native mobile
video products you'll see those over
time more tightly and I think elegantly
integrated into the kinds of services
we're building for twitter but i think
that the next CEO has to have the
ability to again break out of whatever
sort of constraints that that person
might think they need to be able to
break out of you more than anyone know
the difficulties of getting big
organizations to move quickly use
express frustration about the the
trolling problem on Twitter you've been
talking about things like total audience
so putting advertising in places where
people aren't necessarily logged in to
Twitter or they're seeing syndicated
tweets on other websites how should the
next CEO think about getting this
company to innovate at a pace that's
satisfying to Wall Street into its its
its users well I'll say two specific
things about that one we have a very
very concrete and specific long-term
strategy in service toward developing
that total audience and that's
developing content that's engaging for
the logged-in users the more than half a
billion users who come to Twitter and
don't log in and then and the other as
we've articulated it as over 700 million
users we reach in syndication so that
strategy and that product strategy are
all about creating content experiences
that are both engaging and in the moment
and monetizable across that spectrum
body some execution on that vision than
satisfying the pace of execution this
year has been more than satisfying to me
at the end of last year I said on one of
our our earnings calls about last year
that the pace of execution wasn't where
I wanted to see it and our analysts day
in November Kevin wheel sitting right
next to me said to the audience and
investors in the room you're going to
see a pace of execution from us next
year that you haven't seen
us before and that was owed to his
confidence in the team his confidence
and how well he and Alex and engineering
work together and I've seen that from
them now it's going to unfold and
continue to unfold over the course of
this year and we've got things rolling
out this fall that I'm over the moon
about and can't wait for people to see
and I think once people see all that
come together they'll understand how
we're talking about this total audience
strategy and why we feel confident we
can monetize that total audience